have revenue options on the table there
are she's talking about joe manchin that
pays zero taxes and by making savvy
revenue choices for example using a real
corporate profit approach to dealing
with those corporations that pay zero
porter
you're really you're really banging up
joe manchin
and
and the koch brothers
all that all that profit that that
taxation of private you're talking about
that all goes into the investment of joe
manchin making sure he's voting against
infrastructure spending jesus christ
let's let's watch her finish slam dunk
in his ass 100 billion if we use the
corporate minimum tax approach we're
going to generate 40 billion
right there right there senator mansion
right there anyone who's worried about
spending we can generate the revenue so
that this isn't
about 3.5 trillion in spending it's not
even now about 3.5 trillion yeah i i i i
can't remember she makes this point here
but really that's the reason why they
don't want it that's the reason why they
didn't want the coronavirus bills
the relief coronaviru
coronavirus relief bills number one they
did not want to show the american people
that yes we can't afford
to make sure that you you don't lose
your lifestyle
over something that is out of your
control
like they they don't they didn't want
that they didn't want to prove the
government can actually afford [ __ ]
they didn't want that and the reason why
they don't want this infrastructure
build to be as big is because they don't
want to prove to america that hey we can
do big infrastructure things and it and
it helps the economy it helps jobs
it helps you the american people that
money
eventually works its way into your
pocket and into your communities
because we're going to generate the
revenue to pay for these things i have
the will to do it the question is does
senator manchin or is he more concerned
about his corporate donors including
large corporations the oil and gas
industry the big pharmaceutical industry
under our current tax system something
costs a
then you have to slam dunk that
[ __ ]
or you can